the early pre-screening reviews for
spider-man far from home are officially
out and they are all simply fantastic
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
like I just said the embargo for
everybody that a same spider-man far
from home has officially lifted and the
reviews are in and everybody is saying
that this movie is just amazing a lot of
people have even reported that this is
their favorite spider-man movie that has
ever been made and according to several
different reviews and reports there are
many different twists in the movie that
you just do not expect to happen now the
unexpected twists are kind of expected
because this is the first movie where
we're having a character crossover into
our main universe from another universe
in Doctor Strange we saw the ancient
once in dr. Stephen strange through
multiple universes but this is the first
movie where we're going to have a
character from one universe cross into
another universe so there is definitely
going to be some huge twists in the
movie one of which is apparently in one
of the post-credits scenes for
spider-man far from home and has
something to do with a call back to the
original Sam Raimi spider-man movies now
even though we do not know any
particular zaboo post-credit scenes for
spider-man far from home none that we
can confirm are true at least we do know
thanks to some of the reviews from
Twitter that one of them may have a
callback to the original spider-man a
tweet from Michael Blackman over at
BuzzFeed said still thinking about
spider-man far from home which might be
my faves bitey film now Jake Gyllenhaal
is incredible a force and the post
credit scene will make fans of the
original Tobey Maguire movies nostalgic
can't wait to see it again
now obviously Michael saw the
pre-screening and saw that - post
credits scenes that spider-man far from
home has and like he just said one of
them is going to make fans of the
original Tobey Maguire Sam Raimi
spider-man movies nostalgic so what does
this mean well it is a movie that has a
multiverse in it and we did just have an
animated spider-verse movie so is it
possible that we're finally going to see
that iconic spider-man meme in the
post-credits scene and spider-man far
from home with Tobey Maguire and Tom
Holland again it's very possible with
the multiverse being a big part of
spider-man far from home
not to mention Tom Holland has
breasts interest before in doing a
spider-man film with Tobey Maguire
spider-man and Andrew Garfield
spider-man
perhaps there is some sort of a
reference to this in spider-man far from
homes post-credits scene there has also
been word that it could be the
introduction of Jay Jay Jay good old
john jonah jameson played by the
original actor JK Simmons from the
original Sam Raimi spider-man films some
have said that JK Simmons is back
reprising his role as JJJ of the Daily
Bugle as an MCU version and that JJJ and
the Daily Bugle will be a part of the
next spider-man film that is coming out
this would obviously make fans very
nostalgic of the Tobey Maguire
spider-man movies as well as JK Simmons
role of JJJ was a huge fan favorite
character and I'm sure fans would
definitely welcome him back although
nothing is confirmed and the tweet does
mention Tobey Maguire by name but either
way whether it is Tobey Maguire
appearing as spider-man or even just
appearing as himself or JK Simmons
reprising his role as JJJ in the MCU
fans will definitely feel nostalgic
about one of the spider-man far from
home post credits scenes but which would
you prefer would you like to see Tobey
Maguire come back as spider-man or would
you like to see JK Simmons or Prizes
role of JJJ moving forward in the MCU in
spider-man films be sure to comment with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
the giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man far
from home as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof